zum Schluss eine kleine lrommel wir
nennen das Fragenlotto die Nieten und
die Gewinnerlose sind gekennzeichnet die
Nieten sind unverschämte dreiste Fragen
die grünne sind harmlose
Fragen die so ein bisschen schleimig
sind also wie sie
kann man wählen man kann wählen Sie
können jetzt Zen wie auf der Kirmis sie
können so viel ziehen sie müssen auch
nicht beantworten wenn sie zugemeint
selber öffnenel ja doch die müssen
richtig böse
sein soll ich s selber Vorlesen ja bitte
welche Größe geben sie an und wie groß
sind sie
wirklich oh das ist eine ganz böse frage
ich gebe 173 an und bin in Wirklichkeit
174 ist so ich glaube in kein Wort doch
doch ich bin so groß gut okay g noch
eine sie haben noch eine sie können
wieder mich angucken okay ich darf nicht
gucken wir sind jetzt ich darf nicht
schauen was ich nehme doch doch die
dürfen auch schauen was dürfen auch sie
dürfen wählen doch doch das ist jetzt
eine schleimfrage das ist eine
schleimfrage okay
entwerfen sie ihre Kostüme selbst nein
nein das kann ich nicht das mach meine
Frau ehrlich ja also in der Familie ja
ja und gucken sie dann drüber und ich
habe aufgegeben ja ja ich würde am
liebsten so auf die Bühne gehen aber das
findet meine Frau nicht so gut und sie
ist Chef der also muss du dem Chef sein
Gebiet überlassen noch ja ja ja spannend
ja ja okay gut ich will die bösen die
machen auch mehr
Spaß wieso denken wohl die Leute immer
ich sei so klein ich bin gar nicht so
klein so jetzt den hat jemand gesagt
Mama der ist ja viel größer das steht in
irgendeiner Bio es gibt ja so Sachen die
setzen sich fest die Stimmen überhaupt
nicht und die kommen immer Wied hab ich
auch ja bei mir steht in in allen BIOS
irgendwo ich habe 250 goldene und weiß
ich wie viel Platin Platten ich hätte
gerne so viel aber das stimmt nicht
irgendwann hat es sich mal durchgesetzt
und unterdessen sage ich auch nichts
mehr wann lernen Sie englische
Aussprache this is a very good question
I will try my very best in the
future
gut muss ich noch mehr noch eins nein
wie Sie möchten wie Sie möchten sie
können aufhören sie können das Spannende
ist wir hatten letztlich eine
Schauspielerin die sagt so ich will
jetzt nicht mehr und dann war sie aber
so neugierig und
weil wir überlegen uns die ja immer ganz
gezielt leiden sie unter Haarausfall ja
natürlich sonst hätte ich nicht so eine
hohe stiren und ich habe sogar letz mal
Fernsehbilder von mir gesehen da habe
ich mich gefragt wer ist denn der Mann
der da hinten so keine Haare hat das war
ich ja ja der Zahn der Zeit nagt schauen
ich glaub wenn man dann den Punkt
überwunden hat die Fans zu verlieren
dann ist es glaub ich kein Problem mehr
wenn die das wenn es mal akzeptiert ist
und ja genau ich habe das ja ich bin ja
da nicht so schwieriger Fall welches
ihre Talente haben sie noch nicht dem
Publikum
präsentiert von mir weiß man alles ich
bin eigentlich ein offenes
Buch noch eine nehme ich ja okay ich
wollte schon sagen Poken pokan aber auch
das hat man schon gesehen ja ja ja hat
man schon
gesehen vielleicht eine handwerkliche
Tätigkeit oder was was im im textiles
gestalten
nähen haben sie
Flugangst Respekt VM Fliegen habe ich
aber Flugangst nicht so wunderbar vielen
Dank